so now you have this this
business or this platform or people know
that you are the name behind a hit do
people start sending you material
well i mean i was in a difficult
position because i'd had my first hit
record i owe the bank five hundred
thousand dollars um and i don't have a
job but you don't make money having the
hit record well it wasn't my company so
i didn't have any money um and so i had
to
repay the bank
what they'd loaned me to buy the shares
uh i had to sell my house my car oh my
god so i went to i went to live with my
mum and dad again
uh i never wanted to leave in the first
place by the way so i was quite happy i
just went like you know what
uh didn't work out i'm in a bit of a
scrape how old are you at this point i'm
probably about 27 28
um
and uh
i i was very lucky i found uh a bank
manager who believed in me and he said
i'll tell you what i'll do simon i will
give you a loan and you've got to pay it
back to me because like if you've done
it you know once you'll probably do it
again so i'm gonna back you
so
and it took me about
four years to pay everything back um
but it was interesting because
everything i thought i loved you know
like my stupid porsche or my house
honestly i couldn't care less i just
gave everything back and i thought we'll
just going to start again my mum and dad
were thrilled because they never wanted
me to leave in the first place
no
no so you what was the next uh milestone
as far as uh song or music or did you
well then i had to find a label who or a
major company who would back me and
most of the people i initially met went
no
and then i found
one person who said we'll give you a
year but within that year you've got to
sell x amount of records so i'm like
okay
and fortunately i did and that's kind of
how i started being an anr guy and you
know i got and then you you because he
has he's historically attached to so
many things that we know about i think
we were talking last time i was talking
about music you you told me about um
was the britney spears hit uh um hit me
baby one more time yeah yeah you were
involved in that
no i wish i was uh i'd met
i first of all i met uh max martin
um for those that don't know max martin
probably has written
some of the biggest pop hits that you
know for kitty perry for britney spears
for all those young yeah i mean going
back and seeing backstreet um backstreet
boys brittany um i mean
the list is endless he's genius
and
these group of producers
were
working in sweden and i tracked them
down and there was a guy called wasn't
his real name but his name was dennis
pop with a z
and he had put all these producers
together right i found them a little bit
like
he's at the background now like in in
stockholm heard all these songs and i
thought my god they're going to change
pop music you you were able to identify
that yeah it was just
unbelievable going into that complex
incredible it was phenomenal and the
tragedy was is that dennis who'd put all
these guys together he passed away just
before
you know everything went kind of crazy
you know where they just dominated and
it's still to this day
and like you said actually you know most
of the great pop songs written even now
they're max and and and his team it's
unbelievable so
do you heard hit me baby one more time
so so i so i knew max i didn't know him
well
and i had a boy band at the time called
five
um who i'd put together and we were just
on the verge of breaking the mid-america
and someone phones me from america and
says i've just been played this song
and it was written for tlc
and he played me tlc was supposed to do
yeah hippie baby one more time was
written for tlc tlc passed
the guy plays it down the phone to me
this song hit me baby one more time i'm
like oh my god i've got to have this on
so i phoned up max i said max please
please give me the song
and he went
i promised it to someone else and i said
well
i'll send you a mercedes fight literally
a mercedes 500 sl
if i can have the song and he went no he
said no yeah i promised it to somebody
else and i went who and he went brittany
spears
i went max let me give you some advice
no one is going to have a hit with a
name called britney spears well she
wasn't even known yet wasn't even known
that why would he
not take the mercedes over this unknown
because he's honorable i mean he'd
promised the song and he wasn't going to
break the promise and
look he he made the right decision i
mean because when i was talking to you
about it that's her first hit yeah and
her first hit was when i first saw it
before it was any place i've gone into a
store diesel diesel diesel jeans i was i
bought jeans for my daughter and in the
diesel genes they gave you a vhs that
came the jeans came folded in a vhs tape
and you would go home and you'd play the
vhs tape and i didn't know who this girl
was britney spears and that was the song
so it wasn't like britney and usher it
had those two songs on it yes yeah yeah
and then when that song went gold i gave
her her gold record at uh on my on my
talk show in 1998 i think that's 1998.
yeah yeah yeah but so you didn't he
didn't take the car
and the rest is history uh and we're
still good friends now and you know it's
it's uh because i listen i would have
taken the i would have taken the car
uh but and don't forget you know no one
had ever heard of this girl before so
you know he was not gonna break his
promise and um so i missed out on that
but that's how you know we sort of met
and became friends
[Music]